i
[Música]
les voy a pedir a todos por favor y si
pueden cerrar esos ojos que imaginemos
por un momento que estamos en un lugar
súper como están flotando en una alberca
de agua muy tibia se sienten súper a
gusto hay alguien que te trae comida
constantemente una luz muy tenue de
fondo y una música con un beat muy
interesante alguien te está diciendo
palabras lindas todo el día eres el más
consentido consentida del mundo te
sientes súper feliz pero de repente una
fuerza extraña te saca de ese lugar y te
transporta un lugar completamente
distinto
ahí hace frío hay una luz casi segadora
ya no tienes tu comida no te puedes
trasladar y encima todos te hablan como
si te conocieran y no conoces a nadie y
te quieren abrazar
qué sentirías en ese momento seguramente
estarás un poco desconcertado de
zacarías de onda y buscaría es alguien
conocido que te sabe pues probablemente
eso es lo que siente un recién nacido
cuando llega al mundo y busca un refugio
que normalmente su madre nosotros los
adultos a veces estamos tan concentrados
con nuestras necesidades compromisos o
deberes sociales que cuando nace un
nuevo ser nos olvidamos de las
necesidades de él y de la familia que se
acaba de formar
por lo mismo cuando supe que estaba
embarazada me di cuenta que todo mundo
opina sobre lo que deberías de hacer y
de profesión soy ingeniera e
investigadora y me di cuenta que para
ser madre también podía investigar me di
cuenta que una vasta cantidad de
información en torno al embarazo y
cuando te informas temporeras y decides
con decisiones informadas me di cuenta
que yo podía establecer mi plan de parto
y decidir que era lo que quería y decidí
quienes estuvieran conmigo pero
lamentablemente en méxico la mayoría de
las mujeres no tiene esa capacidad de
decisión o más bien no sabemos que
contamos con esa capacidad y tenemos el
derecho a ser respetadas
en méxico entre los países de la ocde se
considera el número uno con incidencia
de cesáreas en américa latina y además
la oms sugiere que esto solo debería
suceder en el 10 y 15% de los casos
según un estudio en mexico
este aumento se debe una mezcla entre el
incentivo económico el tiempo la
comodidad la profesionalización de los
médicos y lamentablemente la falta de
preparación de los padres para el parto
cuando les hablo de que las mujeres
necesitan ser respetadas es únicamente
que nuestras decisiones se tomen en
cuenta de hecho hay diversas
organizaciones en el mundo que buscan
fomentar una ley de parto humanizado o
respetado esto supone únicamente que las
gestantes tengan acceso antes durante y
después del parto para así
posteriormente ellos decidir qué tipo de
parto quien de verdad hay una necesidad
de vivir y de recuperar nuestro poder
como mujeres y ser las protagonistas de
ese momento tan especial y posiblemente
manera ayudaríamos a reducir la
violencia obstétrica que se deriva en
prácticas hospitalarias y es gracias al
desconocimiento y prácticas
hospitalarias innecesarias porque son
rutinarias y bueno ya que nace el bebé
él tiene varias necesidades una de ellas
es establecer la lactancia materna y es
súper impresionante como ellos saben lo
que tienen que hacer y reptan hacia el
pecho de la madre pero sabías que en
méxico el 85 por ciento de las mujeres
no amamantar a sus bebés quizás por
falta de información por pensar que es
muy doloroso pero con la técnica
adecuada la lactancia debe ser indolora
también tenemos la falsa creencia de que
no llenamos a nuestros bebés pero es que
la leche materna tiene muy pocas
calorías entonces los niños necesitan
amamantar se constantemente
otra de las necesidades y de las que más
me gusta es que el bebé necesita estar
pegado se me olvidaba comentarles que la
oms también dice que la lactancia
materna debe ser exclusiva hasta los 6
meses de vida y complementada hasta los
2 años y si el dueto mamá bebé lo quiere
lo puede prolongar por más tiempo y es
una decisión de ellos y de nadie más y
como les comentaba otra de las
necesidades es el contacto piel con piel
y establecer la hora sagrada es el
primer contacto en el pecho de la madre
ayuda muchísimo a establecer la
lactancia materna y también a
desarrollar el vínculo de apego que un
bebé necesita cuando les digo que lo
necesita es porque en realidad lo
necesita es algo como comer dormir e ir
al baño para nosotros de hecho en 1970
berg arias einstein escribió el término
tracking para referirse a aquellos que
necesitan ser constantemente cargados o
en contacto con su madre o una figura de
apego
y bueno en mi caso los primeros seis
meses mi bebé no se quería separar de mí
y tuve no se sigue el rollo ya la
necesidad de tenerlo constantemente
conmigo les digo que no sé si yo porque
me pasaba algo muy curioso cada vez que
a alguien distinto a mí lo agarraban yo
sentía que la sangre me había y aunque
mi cabeza y mi cuerpo me decían mi
cabeza me decía tú está bien no le va a
pasar nada mi cuerpo y mi instinto me
decían todo lo contrario yo le daba un
ejemplo a mi esposo imagina que vas con
un gorila y le quieres quitar a su bebé
te mata verdad pues esa soy yo y
entonces con los bebés que tienen la
necesidad de estar pegados a su madre
porque es parte de la selección natural
es lo que les garantiza la supervivencia
tal como lo dice el pediatra promotor
del apego carlos gonzález
y bueno así fue como empecé a utilizar
distintos tipos de creadores para cargar
cómodamente a mi bebé y con las manos
libres y es que él quería dormir todas
sus siestas encima de mí y como cada
persona es diferente cada bebé también
lo es lo que a unos les funciona a otros
no y para mí se empezó a convertir como
en una adicción una bandolera fular
elástico un fular rígido una mochila o
meitai entre otros y así fue como entré
en el mundo del porte el porteo por
definición es transportar entonces
nosotros lo utilizamos como un medio de
transporte en el que aseguramos el
contacto con el bebé pero también su
fisiología y fisionomía es súper
interesante el papel que juegan las
hormonas cuando estamos en contacto con
nuestra cría resulta que es una de las
maneras en que logramos que se active la
glándula pituitaria y ésta se encarga de
controlar dos hormonas una de ellas es
la prolactina que es la que estimula el
tejido de los senos maternos para
producir la leche y la otra que me gusta
más es la oxitocina esta es la
responsable de accionar el parto
de la expresión de la leche y es la
responsable de que amemos pero también
es un neurotransmisor entonces se
encarga de controlar la empatía y la
formación de vínculos entonces imaginen
estamos promoviendo un desarrollo
cerebral basado en interacciones
amorosas y otra de las cosas que se
accionan cuando estamos en contacto son
las neuronas espejo su función es
reflejar e imitar lo que estamos
observando entonces si han visto este
ejemplo me gusta mucho cuando le decimos
a alguien que nos tome una foto y nos
dicen sonríe y nosotros también estamos
sonriendo como loquitos por detrás pues
aries gracias a estas células y los
neurólogos concuerdan en que tienen una
actividad importantísima en ciertas
capacidades cognitivas que se relacionan
a los procesos de aprendizaje y a la
vida social entonces estamos logrando
que los niños alcancen los hitos del
crecimiento correctamente
bueno en cuanto a las posiciones para
cargar las más recomendadas son de
frente viendo a la madre en la cadera en
la espalda y hay una posición que vale
un poco la pena platicar y está tamizada
en el mundo del porte o por la posible
sobre estimulación y la falta de control
del bebé pero es la posición de frente
viendo al mundo ésta puede ser utilizada
con un cargador adecuado y con asesoría
correcta y es importante asesorarse
también porque hay distintos tipos de
cargadores dependiendo de las
necesidades y del desarrollo del bebé
por eso es muy importante que nos
acerquemos a alguien que esté en
contacto con esta información es
importante que utilicemos cargadores que
sean ergonómicos esto quiere decir que
respetan la posición natural del bebé la
cadera está correcta las rodillas son
más altas están más altas que sus
malditas la tela recoge todo el cuerpo
es decir que no se no jala
es decir que debemos de evitarlas
cangureras debemos respetar la posición
de ranita esta consiste en una apertura
de las piernas 90 grados en el cuerpo en
el porteador y según el instituto
internacional de displasia esta posición
ayuda considerablemente a reducir la
incidencia de cadera en los niños la
incidencia de especia de cadera perdón
y otra de las cosas que me encanta es
que te ayuda a seguir siendo tú
cuando tienes a tu hijo aquí puedes
seguir desarrollando ciertas ciertas
actividades por ejemplo a mí se me
ocurrió abrir una empresa cuando mi bebé
tenía tres meses junto con una amiga y
mientras él dormía encima de mí yo podía
hacer las actividades relacionadas a mi
tienda pero además de las actividades el
estar en contacto ayuda a disminuir la
depresión post-parto por las hormonas
que yo ya les comentaba hay que comentar
que el porteo no es una moda es algo
ancestral muchas culturas con el paso
del tiempo han utilizado diversas
técnicas y distintos tipos de cargadores
para aprovechar el contacto con sus
hijos que dura tan poco y en méxico
tenemos un ejemplo súper bueno que es el
rebozo mexicano que muchas mujeres lo
han utilizado no sé si por necesidad
practicidad o porque conocen los
beneficios de la técnica
el estar en contacto con este tipo de
información tuvo un efecto radical en mi
esposo también yo creo que el estar
presente en el parto fue lo que lo
empoderó y fue el parteaguas eso lo
ayudó también a involucrarse en otras
actividades correspondientes a la
paternidad y también aporte a él
encontraba en el porte un momento de
pasar más con su hijo y establecer un
vínculo más fuerte resulta que en los
hombres también se fomenta un equilibrio
hormonal perteneciente a la paternidad
es decir que la prolactina y la
oxitocina también aumentan por lo tanto
el amor a su hijo también y la
testosterona disminuye es decir que
ellos también tienen campeones
hormonales con razón
según wenger la asociación de para la
paternidad internacional mientras los
hombres están involucrados en
actividades domésticas ayuda a que los
hijos sean mejores a que disminuye la
violencia doméstica ya que haya mejor
una mejor planeación familiar pero aún
tenemos un largo camino por recorrer
porque según las estadísticas entre el
35 y 40 por ciento se dividen las cargas
equitativamente
el estar algo que me gusta mucho también
es que
hemos aprendido a unirnos y empoderarnos
como familia a través de la información
para seguir haciendo cosas que nos
encantan por ejemplo mi esposo y yo
adoramos viajar y esto nos ha ayudado a
seguir haciéndolo algo que nos gusta
tanto como pareja y ahora espero como
familia
es súper importante establecer una red
de apoyo y cuando haces este tipo de
actividades te encuentras con personas
maravillosas que probablemente comparten
tu mismo pensamiento y si no que lo
tolere como una vez escuchen una plática
de ted el reto es tener opiniones
distintas y seguir siendo amigos como
seres humanos y más como padres debemos
apoyarnos y debemos dejar de juzgar
es todos estos hechos me motivaron a
seguirme preparando y estudiar y me
formé como consultora de portero
dicen que no nacemos sabiendo ser padres
pero si podemos investigar para ser
mejores difícilmente creo que podemos
hacer los padres perfectos pero sí
podemos reinventarnos y mejorarnos cada
día para hacer una mejor versión de
nosotros y dar una esperanza a esta
sociedad
creo
y siento a lo mejor es muy idealista
querer cambiar al mundo
pero con pequeñas acciones y con pocos
pasos lo vamos a lograr y para mí y para
muchos el criar a una persona con la
mejor instrucción posible es un gran
paso gracias
[Aplausos]